[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment massive reforms called for at
the National Security Agency over
surveillance on Americans the
information has also had massive
implications in Europe correspondent
Jillian Turner has our story tonight
from Great Britain one time NSA
contractor and CIA employee Edward
Snowden is believed to be in Hong Kong
tonight hiding out after leaking
information the Snowden revelations
shook the world during the summer of
2013 and ever since the National
Security Agency and US Congress have
been embroiled in an epic battle over
the legality of mass surveillance back
then the 29 year old NSA contractor
publicly confessed to stealing a trove
of highly classified intelligence about
US surveillance programs Snowden handed
that Intel over wholesale to the UK's
Guardian newspaper and New York Times
and in the process revealed that the
Intel community was collecting
information about Americans suspected of
having ties to terrorism prompting a
national outcry what Snowden did more
than anything else is he brought one
word to the forefront and that was
privacy get burst the bubble people
thought they had far more privacy than
their really good a lots happened in the
ensuing years since the very public
fallout members of Congress insists
they've used their oversight authority
to tamp down on NSA operations most of
which I can't go into chastened the
nation's leading Intel officials I would
follow the law and I would ensure if
confirmed that the agency follows the
law Congress and the Defense Department
also established US Cyber Command to
provide military support for u.s.
networks and while Intel experts widely
view these steps is effective they also
acknowledge the NSA continues data
collection of Americans about 530
million calls in just a few years the
problem is we're collecting more and
more but the real question is how much
of this are we really processing how
much this is really turning into things
that we can make decisions on European
countries were also hit hard by the
Snowden revelations Britain's government
in particular is still grappling to this
day with major fallout as the u.s.
restricted government access to
America's data Britain's Parliament went
in the opposite direction it passed
legislation known as the snoopers
charter in November 2016 it requires
internet companies to keep logs of
customer browsing data for one year the
law is so contentious here in Britain
it's been fought over in the High Court
virtually since the day it passed and
just last month the court ruled it
violates British citizen's right to
privacy and ordered the government to
draft new legislation by November 1st
Brett Joanne Turner in London Jillian
thank you